- Well, speaking of family,
Bryce shared this old photo,
so we're gonna put that, look, okay.
Where are you there?
- [Bryce] You know, I don't
even really know necessarily.
- But you're winking at us.
- Oh, am I?
Oh, no, I'm, you know what it is.
I'm very sensitive to sun.
- Me too.
- Yes.
So it's very likely that I
just couldn't see anything.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But my family, we
always go on road trips.
That's always the thing that I would do,
kind of like growing up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it would always be these road trips.
And no one enjoyed them
except for my mother.
- Forced family fun.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it was like the second
that the car door was shut,
we knew that there was no escaping
for at least six and a half hours.
And so it was just like, did
you bring the bananas with you?
Like, it was like very intense.
But it was, you know, like there were,
there were definitely a
lot of great memories.
And then there were a few weird ones.
One time my parents were
driving from LA to Yosemite
and they left my 11-year-old brother
in a Krispy Kreme in Los Angeles.
And it took them four
hours to figure it out.
And they arrived in Yosemite.
- [Kelly] Four hours?
- That's bad, that's bad.
- Four hours, yeah.
- What kind of therapy
has this one been through?
- I know, I know.
Well, actually--
- I feel really good
as a mother now.
- I know.
- It's very "Home Alone" actually.
- It's totally "Home Alone."
- Um no, that was reasonable.
That was, no, what?
(Kelly laughing)
No, four hours?
- Four hours.
- He was at a Krispy Kreme,
it's a nice place to hang.
- Yeah, there could be worst places.
- Eight hours because my
parents needed to drive back
to get him.
And my mom cried the entire time.
And they show up
and my, you know, this is
a little stereotypical,
so I apologize if I offend anyone.
He was surrounded by cops
and they were all eating donuts together.
It was fine.
(audience laughing)
- Is what it is.
- [Bryce] He was fine.
- I mean, we all eat donuts,
not just cops, they're good.
- Yes, yes.
- They're good.
- Especially when you get
there and they're warm,
I mean, I've heard.